you have had this extraordinary career
you know I mentioned the auspice in the
introduction and things but Harry Potter
weirds me but that did want to change
your life in a way yeah well yes a lot
of very small people kind of say hello
to me and that way that was nice
different lot of people yes but also to
where that they'd only know you for that
one thing like you've never existed
before
no I never had and except what one
monkey once said to me he said were you
were you really a cat and I heard myself
say just pull yourself together
so there's so that there's the Harry
Potter bit of your life which kind of
changed your life
but then Downton comes along
is that one of those things where you
thought you were famous till you were in
Downton no I I didn't I didn't think
that at all it's every since Downton
that people seem to know but you know
who who stopped me and announcement but
it's only since Downton and that's
that's television for you yes
it's common television but funnily
enough I was I was in waitress in
storing tomato no little boy was at the
checkout with his mother and he kept
looking at me and I thought what am I
gonna do but and he won't kept looking
at me and looking at me and I said could
can I help you and he said it's all
right it'll come to me in a minute
lovely okay
but the the people coming up to you now
like because very Americans are very
well America you know they're not shy
Americans no no no but I don't go
anywhere really where they can get at me
institutionally in museums and art
galleries and things so that limits
things I keep away from men and Herod's
I don't go new so are you in a ways i'm
glad that dampens over oh yeah no I
really am because she honestly she was
about by the tummy of you she must have
been 110 go on and on
I couldn't didn't make sense
Alex I know you you're a big downturn
fat I am
I shouted it a lot you harlot Suzie I do
here we watch it and we shall stir cuz
I'm not in it
have you ever watched dancing
I've got the box set
that's it right there that's
essentially my crazy crazy
that's one nut no no that's - nothing's
bent down like this and I think you
could hear the click you know you just
hear it you get used to that clicking
sound I thought oh yeah these pants are
really like there oh I think my ass is
hanging out